we are just five days away from Pamela
Anderson's new Netflix documentary and
her Memoir that have some folks here in
Hollywood on high alert welcome to
Entertainment Tonight Michelle Turner
will join us in a moment from Miami but
look who's here today from New York City
Rachel Smith usually we see Rachel in
the monitor behind us but today in the
flash now today I'm In the Flesh I gotta
keep you on your toes Kevin Frazier I
believe that all right back to miss
Pamela though because the Nuggets we're
getting so far from this Memoir are
generating a lot of Buzz starting with
one Rocky Revelations
there's lots of lots to talk about lots
to find out I want to take control of
the narrative for the first time Pam's
words Sylvester Stallone offered me a
condo in a Porsche to be his number one
girl and I was like does that mean
there's a number two uh-uh he goes
That's the Best Offer you're gonna get
honey you're in Hollywood now
Stallone's rep denies the claim calling
it quote false and fabricated Sam's Pam
has a little Hollywood Hit List Sly X
Tommy Lee who she says trashed her
trailer because he was jealous of a TV
kiss with David chokachi and then
there's Tim Allen damn got a minute in
the pilot I was wearing cutoffs you know
my tool belts
Thank you Lisa the 55 year old who
played the original Tool Time girl
writes I walked out of my dressing room
he opened his robe and flashed me
quickly completely naked underneath he
said it was only fair because he had
seen me naked now we're even I left
uncomfortably I've always been a writer
I've always known I could write a book I
wrote a book without any help without
any collaborator without any Ghost
Writer our little Pammy and she's the
sweetest girl that's why we love her
they're treating me worse now than they
did before
ET was on the set of Home Improvement
many times and there was plenty of
joking around Tim is like one of my
favorite people in the whole world does
he harass you as much as he harassed me
I don't know buddy harasses he's awesome
stop it I like it when you pick on me
better anyway while Tim denies Pamela's
claims saying no it never happened I
would never do such a thing the
allegations picked up steam after this
clip went viral showing Tim at The Kilt
appearing to flash his TV wife Patricia
Richardson
thank you
the actress came to Tim's defense
clarifying to E.T that Tim was wearing
underwear quote I was just shocked that
he lifted The Kilt not by a man in box
or shorts the two remained friends to
this day and even reunited unless man
standing it's like being around family I
think he matured a lot
he's very mature today Pam doubled down
on her claims telling variety I'm sure
he had no bad intentions times have
changed though I doubt anyone would try
that post me too it's a new world
[Music]